hi I'm British today we will be talking
about trigonometry so this is the first
video on trigonometry and I would like
to start with like why do we want to
study trigonometry and and what is
trigonometry so you will certainly know
that Euclidean geometry is very
fundamental to how we think about nature
like the way we visualize things in
physics for example is we use Euclidean
geometry in the way we think and often
Euclidean geometry requires some amount
of innovative thinking to like reason
about problems and often when you want
to talk about physics you do not want
geometry to be your bottleneck in
thinking about physics so trigonometry
and coordinate geometry are two subjects
which try to make a more systematic
study of geometry
and what is trigonometry trigonometry is
about a study of angles in an algebraic
way so I mean you would know that
algebra you would feel more comfortable
doing algebra and there is like algebra
is often you can something you can do in
a more mechanical wave whereas geometry
often requires a sort of an innovative
leap so using trigonometry we will be
able to reason about geometric problems
in a more algebraic way right so so
let's start with the very basics of what
is an angle right so so you know from
basically clearing geometry that if you
have a circle of radius R then the
perimeter is equal to two PI R so we
know this from basic geometry and like a
basic reasoning will tell you that okay
if I take half of a circle that the
length of the arc of a half a circle is
PI R so if I take this length is pi
times R similarly if I take a quarter
circle so maybe this thing this will be
like PI by two R
right so in general like if I if I pick
out an angle of let us say alpha degrees
right like this could be like sixty
degrees then you can easily reason that
the length of an arc with angle alpha
degrees is alpha over 360 times two PI R
right so this is just basic ratio and
proportion type of argument right so let
me write this as two pi alpha 360 times
R right so so the like be R more
generally taught since school we have
been usually taught to think in terms of
degrees and the full circle has 360
degrees but now when we want to write
the length of an arc now we have to
write this annoying expression which is
two pi alpha over 360 times R so it
would be much nicer to call this
expression two pi alpha power 360 as the
angle itself instead of alpha degrees if
we call if you could call this as the
angle itself
so let us if you could define this
quantity as the angle then it would be
much nicer so so as you like as there
are different ways to measure objects
like length you measure it in meters or
inches and so on similarly this is a
different unit of measuring angles so
this is angle in radians and thinking in
terms of radians is very important like
my math teacher used to tell me that you
know when you are learning a new
language you like for example if I am
trying to speak in English I should if I
want to learn it well I should not think
in a different language like think in
Hindi and translate to English every
time I am speaking
should really start thinking in English
if you want to learn English well right
similarly here thinking in terms of
Radiance
is often the better thing to do because
now I can write length of arc with angle
theta in radians is is just R times
theta so that is why thinking in terms
of radians is often the more natural way
to think about angles now let's just to
be more familiar with this conversion
let us see that for example 360 degrees
you know is two pi radians that is what
we just saw it right the perimeter of
the entire circle is 2 PI R and 2 pi is
the angle of the entire circle similarly
180 degrees is like PI 90 degrees is
like PI over 2 and so on so we just saw
how to measure angles in degrees and
radians and we said that radians is the
more natural unit to think about angles
so that now the length of the arc with
angle of theta radians is just R times
theta so in the rest of the video we
will talk about trigonometric ratios we
will define what they are and we will
talk about some trigonometric identities
like these are the algebraic tools which
will help us reason about angles in a
more algebraic way ok so let's look at
an angle and let's say that the angle is
Theta so whenever you write theta as the
angle it is assumed that it's in radians
because radiance is as we know the more
natural way of thinking about angles and
now let's say that the radius is R so we
we just saw from here that the length of
the arc is R times
theta right now there are other
interesting parameters that you would
want to know about the angle for example
if I drop a perpendicular from here
right what is the height of this line
segment so so let us call this line
segment so let us call this a B and C so
this line segment is the Aang the side
that is opposite to our angle the side
AC is the side that is adjacent to our
angle and this side is the hypotenuse
right so we would like to know what the
height of this sega line segment BC is
and one thing that you would know from
similarity of triangles is that suppose
I have two triangles like this a C let
us say this is D and E and this is our
angle theta
you know from similarity of triangles
that BC divided by a B is equal to so
note that these are right angles equal
to de divided by e d right so these are
two triangles which have all three
angles the same and therefore they are
similar so the ratio of sides are equal
right so now this by similarity or since
because of similarity of triangles this
ratio is purely a property of the of the
angle and it is not a property of any of
the sides so we define this quantity
this quantity is defined as the sine of
the angle sine of the angle
right so to remember it more easily
let us call sine theta as the opposite
side divided by the hypotenuse right now
and so for example now you would see
that in this thing if this the
hypotenuse is are the length of the
opposite side is now R times sine theta
similarly now we can define the ratio of
the adjacent upon the hypotenuse so so
that is defined as cos theta
so now the adjacent side
if since the hypotenuse of the plant are
this thing is of length cos theta right
so in terms of this ratio it will be a C
divided by a B which is also same as a
divided by ad this is the cause of the
angle and by similarity of triangles
this is just a property of the angle and
does not depend on the sides of the
triangle okay so now we will see our
first trigonometric identity right from
Pythagoras theorem
we know that for any right angle
triangle the sum of squares of the two
sides is equal to the square of the
hypotenuse so let me write it here in
the colloquial language opposite square
plus adjacent square is equal to
hypotenuse square this is what
Pythagoras theorem tells us and if we
divide by hypotenuse square throughout
we get that opposite upon I put in a
square plus adjacent upon hypotenuse
square is one right but if you look at
our definitions of sine theta and cos
theta this tells us that sine theta
square plus cos theta square is equal to
1 now a usual convention to write sine
theta square is like you do not want to
write the brackets all the time so what
you do is you write it as sine square
theta and cos square theta so as to not
confuse with for example sine theta
square this would mean sine of theta
square whereas this is sine of theta the
whole square